翻訳: Noriaki Ohta
校正: Hiroko Kawano
建築家の仕事
住宅とか ビルとか お店とか
建ってるものは何でもデザインしたい
というのが建築家です
めちゃくちゃ楽しい仕事なんです
例えば すごく小さな 公衆トイレ
めちゃめちゃ大きな 国立競技場とか
そういうのも全部 デザインしたいんです
たまには
「コンペの時と 形変わっとるやんけ」
とかですね
「予算なんか大きくなってないか？」
色んなこと言われます
辛い時もあります
でも やっぱり根本的に楽しいんです
何で楽しいって言えるか？
まぁ僕たち 建物作るって言いますけど
実際には毎日毎日 徹夜をして
何してるかと言いますと 模型を作っています
模型を作ったり壊したり
いくつも作って並べてみたり
もうそれが楽しいんです
模型作ったり壊したりするから
色々言われてもストレスは溜まりません
でも 模型を作ったり壊したり
もうそれで楽しくやっているうちに
プロジェクトがなくなってしまうことは
よくあります
ですから 実際の作品よりも作った模型の数は
圧倒的に多いんです
同時に僕は大学で先生もしています
でも実際にやっていることは変わりません
こうやって学生さん達がやって来て
自分たちのプロジェクトの模型を
説明してくれるんですね
大体僕がやることと言ったら
模型を壊すんです
（笑）
いい表情ですよね
でも 壊すことによって構造的に
どこらへんに課題があるんだ？とか
もっと可能性あるんじゃないか？とかですね
アイデアを育てていくことができるんです
今日はそういう模型の話をしたいと思うんです
皆さんは建築の模型っていうと
大きなビルのロビーにある 綺麗な完成模型
あるいは博物館の展示されている
街のジオラマ模型
そういうものを想像するかもしれません
ああいうのは 見せるための模型なんですね
プロがすごく器用な技で 綺麗に作って
これはもちろん壊したら ダメですよ
ですが僕らが普段 付き合うのは
作ったり壊したり
アイデアを育てるための使う模型なんです
今日は特に 私たちが暮らしている
街の模型を作って使う
その思わぬ効果の話をしたいと思います
このことを 僕たちは東日本大震災の
復興支援の中で教わったんです
2011年3月11日
このとき僕は神戸にいて テレビの画面から
長い間かけて出来てきた
町や村が一瞬にして無くなってしまう
津波で一瞬にして流されてしまう
その光景を目の当たりにしました
建築を一生の仕事にしようと思って
頑張っている僕にとっては
非常に大きな衝撃でした
実は仙台から神戸に引っ越してきて
１年目のことでした
ちょうど初めて受け持った学生たちを
卒業式で送り出す直前の出来事で
学生たちにとっても 建築に夢を抱いて
学んできた彼らが目にする光景としては
あまりに過酷だなと思ったんです
同時に僕が６年半お世話になってきた
東北の皆さん
今 そういう状況になって
どんな声をかけたらいいのかな？
建築で人の心を癒すっていうのは
どうやってやったらいいんだろう？
その時考えました
ちょうどその年の２週間後 3月24日
大学の卒業式の後で小さなパーティーを
学生たちと開きました
その中で
建築に人を癒すことができるんだろうか？
建築学生に被災地の皆さんのために
できることって何かあるんだろうか？
そういうことを話し合いました
その中で出てきたアイデアが
街をモケイで復元するということ
それをみんなで作るということ
作ったものを被災地の皆さんに
見てもらうということ
この単純な３つのことでした
私たちはこのプロジェクトを
「失われた街 模型復元プロジェクト」
と呼んで
全国の建築家や建築学生
皆さんと一緒になって
これまで５年間続けてきています
今日はここに 実物を１つ持ってきました
これは仙台市の荒浜という海岸の
震災前の模型です
海沿いに防風林があって
その背後に
住宅がたくさん広がっている風景です
私が仙台にいたころ
学生たちとこの海岸でよくBBQしました
非常に愛着のある場所です
でも今は 津波で全て流されて
影も形もありません
東日本大震災で 津波の被害を受けたエリアは
南北で550kmにわたります
そこにたくさんの街や集落がありました
この模型は１m四方で作られています
縮尺は500分の１という縮尺です
１辺が500mですから
500m四方というと皆さんどうですか？
まぁ散歩して歩き回るような
そういうご近所の空間です
この模型で換算すると東日本大震災で
津波で被災をした市街地
人が住んでいた場所は
約1000個分ぐらいになります
この模型は４、５人の大学院生が
２週間かかって作り上げるような代物です
1000個と言うとトンデモない数ですよね
実際に模型でも大変なんだから
本当の復興というのは計り知れない
エネルギーがかかる
そういうものだと感じています
僕たちは全国の学生さんに声をかけて５年間
およそ４割ぐらいの部分を
作った計算になります
関わった学生は のべで言うと
もう1000人を超えています
それでもまだ全体を作るには至っていません
この作った白い模型を
現地に持っていくとですね
実際に被災地の人たちは
津波でずっと住んできた街が
無くなってしまっているから
そこに住んでいる訳じゃない
思い出そうにも
そこに街の景色がないので
そこで住んでいた頃のことを
なかなか思い出すのができない
なので模型を見ると皆さん口々に
「ここが私の家だ」
「この道をよく通ったんだよね」
「ここから桜が見えて
春には毎年ここでピクニックしてたんだよね」
色んな話が出てきます
盛り上がってくると
もう話が聞こえなくなるぐらい
賑やかに 時には笑い声すら聞こえるような
そういう展示会になります
中には震災のショックで
津波の直前のこと それまでのこと
もう思い出せない
となってしまっていた おばあさんが
模型を覗き込むことで
思い出を取り戻す
そういったシーンも見られました
学生たちが作った白い模型を囲んで
地域の皆さんから
たくさんの思い出を聞くわけですが
それらを小さな透明な旗に書いて
その場所に立てていきます
また 白い模型の家の屋根は
住んでいた方々に
ご自身の屋根の色を塗ってもらいます
１週間かけて白かった模型は
皆さんの思い出が載った
懐かしい風景に変わっていきます
時にはご夫婦で来られた方が
屋根の色で
ちょっと喧嘩になっちゃうこともあります
「何色だったっけ？」
「青でしょ？」
「いや、黒だ」みたいな話ですね
（笑）
この岩手県 田老町の模型の風景ですけれども
小学校の校庭で毎年行われていた運動会
そこで毎年 集落対抗で応援合戦をしていた
その時の風景を 模型に追加して再現しました
地図や航空写真では載っていないような
街の様々な風景が
この模型の上にどんどん載っていきます
これを僕たちは
「記憶の街ワークショップ」と呼んで
これまでに44の地域で行っています
１つ例を紹介します
岩手県の大槌町
２つの川に挟まれて
中心部に
とても可愛らしい街が作られていた地域です
ご覧のように津波で
何もかも無くなってしまいました
この部分を大学で３m×３m
９ピクセルの白い模型を作って
地域に運びました
１週間のワークショップでこのように
色とりどりの懐かしい大槌の風景が
蘇りました
模型を覗き込むと
毎年秋になると遡ってくる鮭を
大漁を記念して行われていた
鮭まつりの光景が再現されています
この模型をご覧になった住民の方が
また連鎖的に別の思い出を思い出されます
大槌には 地下から自噴する湧水が
井戸となって何十箇所と街中にあって
そのことがこの大槌の中心街にだけ
井戸端会議をする文化というものを作っていた
そのことが
このワークショップからも分かりました
住民の方もこの模型を囲んで
色々お話しすることで
この地域が持っていた魅力や特徴
そういうものを再認識するんです
これは陸前高田の街を再現した
ワークショップの模型です
この模型の上には
5000本を超える旗が立っています
もはや模型というより
本当の街のようだと思いませんか？
実際の街は津波で壊されてしまったし
これから新しく作られる街は
以前のものとは
ずいぶん変わったものになってしまう
自分たちは街を失ってしまった
でも この模型の上に
1000名以上の来場者の皆さんから
思い出されて記録された
思い出が作る風景は
これは本当の街と言ってもいいんじゃないか？
そんな風に思うわけです
街は学生たちが作った見せる模型
住民の皆さんと一緒に
作り替えたり 色を塗ったり
使うプロセスを経て
本当の街のようになってしまった
街はハードの建物とか道路とか
そういうもので出来ているんですけれども
でも もう一方で
街はそこに住んできた
皆さんの記憶で出来ていると
言ってもいいんじゃないか？
そんなことをこのワークショップから
私たちは学びました
皆さん どうでしょう？
これ 被災地だけの
話じゃないんじゃないかな？
と思いませんか？
例えば 皆さんが住まわれている地域で
このワークショップをやったら
皆さんはどんな旗を
どこに立てようと思いますか？
また
どういう人にどんな話を聞いてみたいな
という風に考えますか？
毎日顔を合わせているご家族
あるいは毎日すれ違う近所の人
なかなか街の話をする機会は
そんなに多くあるものじゃないと思います
でも模型を囲むと
自然と色んな話が出てきます
皆さんの身近な人が
意外な良い場所を知ってるかもしれません
色んな街の記憶を聞いているうちに
だんだんその街が好きになっていきます
みんなの街の記憶は 街の宝物です
街をみんなで作るための宝物
それをシェアすることで
街を作っていくアクションは
自然に生まれてくる
そんな風に思いませんか？
街の未来を作るのは
市長さんじゃありません
建築家でもありません
街の未来を作るのはそこに住んでいる私たち
そう思うんですね
ぜひ皆さん
考えてみていただければと思います
ありがとうございました
(拍手)